As you just saw on the quiz, there's three kinds of view we can take with regard to running time.
We can take a best-case view and assume that all the inputs that we're getting are the ones that
make our algorithms run the fastest or we can take the very opposite view
and say that the running time of our algorithm is going to be determined by the worst possible input
that it can receive or we can define running time as the average time that our algorithm will take
over a number of inputs.
Which one of the three are we going to choose in this course?
Best-case running time as you've seen in the previous quiz is often rather trivial or meaningless.
So for example, if we use best-case running time for our algorithm that counts the number of As,
it would only be valid for strings that contain no A at all so we're not going to take this.
For the average-case view, actually that could be a very interesting view and practice
because when we run the algorithm a couple of times we might not care about
how much that algorithm runs on a single run but over many inputs.
But as you've just seen in the quiz, it's actually quite hard to define what an average input looks like.
And also when we do the analysis of an algorithm
sometimes we might not even know what kinds of input the algorithm receives.
Average-case analysis is very interesting sometimes.
But here, it's actually not that suitable. Now, worst-case analysis.
Well we always assume that the algorithm receives an input that
makes it run as long as possible might seem a bit pessimistic to you.
It's almost like we had a mean adversary who was trying to give us the worst possible inputs.
But on the other hand, the advantage of worst-case analysis is that it offers guarantees.
What I mean by that is when we take a worst-case view we know that our algorithm
will not run longer than the worst-case analysis suggests no matter what happens.
And this is actually what we're interested in in this course so we are going to use worst-case analysis.
Meaning, we're always going to state the time of our algorithm for the worst possible input.